jim chasser bonjour c'est avons bon
katia bonjean michael mont-joli nick
shadow
bonjour alors on le sait vous êtes l'un
des signataires de l'appel pour une
primaire à gauche qui a fait l'objet de
vives discussions encore cette semaine
on a l'impression que chaque camp on
essaye de reporter la responsabilité
d'un échec sur sur l'autre françois
hollande par la voix de cambadélis se
dit prêt à y aller mais seulement si
jean luc mélenchon y va lequel dit pas
question d'y aller puisque pas question
de soutenir hollande si jamais il gagne
c'est que ça a l'air d'être assez mal
embarquée quand même en plus que c'est
difficile c'est difficile mais est ce
que finalement si mélenchon et hollande
sont pas d'accord avec le fait que la
gauche et les écologistes que les
citoyennes et les citoyens se
réapproprient la politique qu'ils aient
pas envie d'aller au crash démocratique
en 2017 et d'être contraint comme ça
s'est passé en paca ailleurs de voter
pour un candidat de droite pour éviter
l'extrême droite
qu'est ce qu'on fait on s'arrête de
penser on considère que françois
hollande est candidat naturel d'un droit
naturel comme y avait il ya deux siècles
un droit divin que françois hollande ne
peux pas alors qu'ils pensent matin midi
et soir l'élection présidentielle qui
nous a fait le coup de la déchéance et
de la réforme constitutionnelle pour
l'élection présidentielle
il pourrait pas participer à trois
débats ils ne pourraient pas venir
expliquer qu est ce qu il a fait de son
quinquennat alors que son camp pour le
moins est perturbée confus un peu
déstabilisés par rapport aux promesses
de 2012 et que mélenchon lui se voit
comme le candidat incarnant le peuple
alexandre est indispensable à ces deux
personnalités politiques dans cette n'en
course
la présence des forces politiques de
gauche et écologique saissac
indispensable moi je me refuse à ce que
la politique soit aujourd'hui accaparé
qu'on soit tous l'otage des ego ou des
ambitions des unes et des 1
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin
notre primaire c'est un ballon d'oxygène
dans la politique française
on voit à caen qui est totalement
assommé qui est totalement à 6 et donc a
besoin qu on ouvre les portes qu'à
besoin qu'on ouvre des fenêtres cas
besoin de débattre en chemin est-ce
qu'il faut pas débattre aujourd'hui à
gauche sur le chômage sur tous les
sujets dont on a parlé aujourd'hui
justement ont compris à des différences
d'appréciation au sein des 10
de sensibilité de gauche et écologistes
donc c'est sainte qu'il faut discuter et
puis lyon ce processus démocratique dont
on connaît pas la fin c'est ça qu'on
allait faire sur ces questions d'idées
dont vous parlez la question du chômage
qui dit candidature commune dit
programme commun comment aujourd'hui on
peut considérer que la gauche puisse
avoir un programme commun allant de
jean-luc mélenchon à emmanuel macron est
ce que c'est possible
moi je veux des idées je me fous
aujourd'hui d'aider des personnes qui
pensent avoir un destin présidentiel sur
les ide est justement le programme est
bien mais sion nous note je dis pas que
c'est facile mais est ce que on gère pas
y compris dans ses différentes
sensibilités des villes
est-ce qu'on gère pas des régions est-ce
que nous sommes définitivement
irréconciliables qui nous éloignent un
pardon a surtout l'impression que vous
occuper le terrain en tout cas c'est une
tentative
c'est une tentative que les
sympathisants de gauche et écologistes
que les électeurs de gauche l'écologie
se réapproprie l'élection présidentielle
parce qu'aujourd'hui au fond tout le
monde est résigné potentiellement à ce
que ce soit sarkozy et le pen au second
tour ce qui serait une catastrophe pour
ce pays selon moi et pour une
déflagration énormes progrès vous rendez
compte on a tous été surpris quand même
un peu en 2002 le fait que la gauche
soit pas au 2e tour et que ce soit le
front national là on a l'impression
qu'on est en train de s'y résigner il ya
six semaines après les élections
régionales
sur ce plateau est sûr de tout le monde
disait faut tout changer
et maintenant il faut plus rien changer
il faut y aller au massacre comme ça en
106 ans l'année dernière question sur la
question de la primaire vous avez
annoncé que vous souhaitez organiser le
scrutin le même jour que les huit maires
de droite ça veut dire grosso modo cela
vous passionner honnêtement ça ça va pas
ça va pas vous passionner que c'est en
cette respiration démocratique à droite
et qui en même temps cette respiration
démocratique algues 11 novembre 2016
fois il veut dire une campagne qui
commencerait au début
la fin de l'été quelque chose comme ça
même après en gros huit mois de campagne
jusqu'à laquelle à l'élection
présidentielle est ce que c'est possible
et en présidant à droite quand la date
limite de dépôt des candidatures à
droite c'est quand c'est septembre 79
c'est en septembre on peut faire
exactement la magouille à septembre
mais jusqu'à la lie au président mais ça
hein ça empêche pas d'agir d'accord
jeudi ont parlé de la crise agricole on
peut parler du show dresse devant nous
deux ça n'empêche pas d'agir mais on
sait que l'obsession c'est la
présidentielle donc à partir du moment
où de toute façon en à l'automne
l'obsession sera l'élection
présidentielle il va y avoir le camp de
droite qui va y compris peut-être
s'engueuler confronté à marquer leurs
divergences mais tout le monde sait que
les français en ont envie et tout le
monde s'extasie mobile et il doit avoir
un chef de l'état s'engueuler avec ses
partenaires
mais les français ont peut-être il vous
a pas échappé que 80 % de l'électorat de
gauche et de l'électorat français
d'ailleurs ne voulons ni de nicolas
sarkozy ni de françois hollande ni de
marine le pen
les français ils ont envie de débat est
ce que vous trouvez normal que le
dernier débat au fond ça a été en 2012
et qu'au fond le président de la
république qui pour le mois s'est un peu
écarté des promesses qu'il a faites pour
être élu il n'aurait pas se justifier
vis-à-vis du camp qui l'a élu et qu'il
irait juste au mois de mars en faisant
elle est une réminiscence si françois
hollande ne va pas vous avez dit qu'il y
aurait une candidature écologiste c'est
une sorte de menace qui pour qui pour la
porter cette candidature s'était arrêté
de penser aux personnes les gens ils
s'en foutent des personnes qui à un
moment il faille incarné dans une
élection présidentielle c'est une
évidence il faut emmener les gens sur un
projet il faut avoir la sincérité et
tout ça mais si vous mettez les
personnes au début de sa tout est mort
donc arrêter si le président de la
république ne bouge pas d'ici mars
prochain d'ici avril prochain au fond
oui il y aura des candidatures écologie
parce que même nicolas hulot ne veut pas
rentrer dans ce gouvernement et donc tu
auras lui ont dégringolé jeudi il y aura
mélenchon il y en aura d'autres eh ben
le camp de la gauche ira divisé et
l'humiliation subie même vous le sait
que son bras
aussi jamie se présente bien sûr c'est
un excellent candidat ce sera le mot de
la fin merci ce jeu présent s'il se
présente
merci il ya des cadeaux d'avoir été
l'invité de parlons